joining us exclusively John Solomon he's
what the hell Sarah Carter circa news
Sarah let me start with you we're
talking about bribery we're talking
about blackmail we're talking about what
else that was going on that the Obama
Justice Department knew and still gave
Putin Moscow Russia 20% of our uranium
and the money goes to the Clinton
Foundation let's talk about it well back
in 2009 the FBI was actually approached
by a businessman by an American
businessman who said look I have
information on the Russians and I'm
going to give this to you and they said
would you work with us they they came to
an agreement he went inside for 15
months Sean for 15 months the FBI was
investigating the Russian nuclear
industry and the agency they knew that
there were kickbacks they knew that
there were bribes and they knew how
dangerous this was to national security
and 15 months had passed in the
investigation and then cepheus 13
members of the governing board approved
the uranium 1 deal to the Russians I
mean this was something that I contacted
FBI officials tonight FBI sources that
were there during that time and they
said the FBI would have had all of this
information it would have been their
duty on the board on the cepheus board
to report that information and so now
what I'm thinking is if they did report
that information it's got to be out
there we've got to be able to FOIA it
we've got to be able to see these
documents and know what was going on and
why the United States government decided
to approve a deal that would give 20% of
US uranium assets to Vladimir Putin with
Russia let me go to you John and your
report in the hill so the FBI basically
has evidence in the form of documents
emails financial records eyewitnesses
proving proving the Russians use bribery
kickbacks extortion and money laundering
is to secure the uranium one deal and
about a hundred and forty five million
dollars kickback to the Clinton
Foundation and they knew it in 2009 they
knew it before they even approve the
deal
yeah you said in your opening monologue
that the Democrats are concerned that
Russian Tamm Russia's tampered with our
election results in 2016 well six years
before that they tampered with our
Nuclear Security the case proved that
the nuclear Russia Russia's nuclear
industry had bribed their way and
compromised the American trucking
company that moved all of Russia's
uranium in the United States
that's a national security threat and
for two years the Obama administration
Hillary Clinton and everybody who's been
quoted has said the Obama administration
had no knowledge of a national security
threat and that's why they didn't have
any problem approving the uranium one
deal well guess what tonight we have a
real national security threat that was
proven in real time in 2009 and it's
going to be interesting to see what
Congress does tomorrow morning Chuck
Grassley has a hearing with jeff
sessions on the seat and i think you
might see some interesting questions and
Sarah so and this is stunning that the
Attorney General of the United States
Eric Holder hid the information he knew
about the bribery the kickbacks the
extortion the money and he also knew as
well as Hillary and had to sign off
along with Hillary Clinton on the deal
even though that we know that they're
trying to influence every aspect of our
security and get control over America's
uranium they still allowed the deal to
go through well and these are many of
the same players right you had rod
Rosenstein rod Rosen Stein then was head
of this investigation when he was in
Maryland looking at the trucking company
and remember this you have a trucking
company that's moving American uranium
that is involved in bribery kickbacks
and all kinds of issues and they're
moving a national security asset uranium
and you have Andrew McCabe who's the
Deputy Director of the FBI now who was
also charged with that investigation so
there's a lot of questions here yes and
Moeller who was in charge that is he
investigate himself so we got Muller
having to investigate his boss now rod
Rosenstein who also and Andrew McCabe of
the FBI and probably James Comey they
all knew about this that's exactly what
we're looking at these are people who
actually knew about this now it's up to
Congress to ask those questions to find
out
why did you decide to allow the Sofia
steel to go through with uranium when
why did you vote YES on this what was
the main option for trying to influence
all of our uranium in this cut right
here's the question have a final exit
question and we'll have more on this
tonight did the DOJ did they
deliberately jeopardize America's
national security knowing all of this
was going on in other words the the
kickbacks bribery extortion money
laundering allowing this deal to go
through without presenting the evidence
and how did the killer II sign off on it
and get all this money to the foundation
John did they risk national security I
think there's some things we don't know
yet it is possible the Justice
Department told vociferous members and
they still voted to approve this deal
and it's possibly you mean they told
them about bribery extortion kickbacks
and money laundering and they still
would allow the deal to go through by
the Russians in our own country we don't
know the answer to that yet that's the
question and I can confirm tonight I'm
reporting this out tonight
senator Grassley chairman of the
Judiciary Committee began in him against
the investigation last week specifically
asking all the C feeis members did you
know there was a criminal investigation
this is going to become one of the most
important investigations that are going
to evolve this fall
Sara give you the last word what's
coming up how far is this story gonna go
can you give us a hint where we're
headed I think the story is gonna go far
I know as well that Senator Grassley had
started this investigation last week and
that he had asked very detailed
questions to the current Sofya spord
members and those board members will now
seek the information that he's asking
for because they're going to be looking
at this is a whole new board that's
gonna that's going to be answering these
questions so it's going to be up to them
to tell the truth and to deliver the
answers to the American people and it's
going to be up to us to keep pushing
this so that answers are delivered
because I do believe national security
was at risk I mean according to every
source no containment they knew about it
this is what a proof there really was a
Russia conspiracy but it's not what the
media reported great work both of you
it's amazing if the work you guys doing
the rest of the media is ignorant